midwives provide care for mothers-to-be
and they also help deliver babies
most are not regulated in the state of
nevada and legislation is being
considered to change that
earlier tonight at six the i-team first
brought us a story about a mother who
was suing a midwife and members of her
team
she had been pregnant with twins but
lost her firstborn during a home birth
both the mother and the defendant sat
down with the i-team sharing very
different versions
of the same events tonight the i-team's
vanessa murphy has the different
viewpoints on this hot button
issue and what changes may happen in our
state
you need a license to serve drinks and
cut hair in nevada but
not to care for moms to be and deliver
their babies in a home there's still not
you know a credential pathway for them
to basically to show the consumer
out there who might be wanting to do it
in home delivery
that there is a difference between
levels of midwives
republican state senator scott hammond
is introducing senate bill 271
to license some midwives there's also a
similar bill being considered in the
assembly
opponents say it would take away a
mother's right to choose
some spoke out in this youtube video by
the group nevada friends of midwives
you're taking my right to choose who i
have at my birth away from me
so i feel safer at home choosing who can
attend my
birth who can care for me and my babies
while some states issue
and require licensing or certification
nevada does not
different national and international
organizations provide certification
here's a look at the different kinds of
midwives traditional midwives may not be
certified or licensed
certified nurse midwives are registered
nurses who are also
educated in graduate level midwifery
programs
they have medical training some work
with physician groups and
have hospital privileges the state board
of nursing reports there are 64
certified nurse midwives in nevada
a certified professional midwife has a
certificate through an
organization like the north american
registry of midwives
executive director ida dara says that's
earned by passing a test and
working under the supervision of an
experienced midwife for prenatal visits
newborn exams and at least 55
births what would you say to critics who
say
they're essentially providing medical
care
without medical training i would say
they're providing midwifery care
with midwifery training 100 deliveries
was the number of deliveries i did my
first
month of my four years of residency
first
month dr stacy mchale is an ovgyn in las
vegas and the president-elect of the
clark county medical society
she says she supports a collaboration
between a midwife
and physician from the start the
differences in the levels of training
are very
are very noticeable and those levels of
training
and the need to have expertise and the
need to have someone to provide
backup if there is an emergency
situation is
crucial for the health of our mothers in
nevada i have seen many of the
complications that can happen
with deliveries even those that we
anticipate are going to be
normal and having home birth
midwives makes me very anxious what
about those
rare emergencies is it worth taking a
chance
nobody looks at their own pregnancy as
taking a chance i mean that's why you're
getting regular prenatal care and
assessment
so that you have a clue if anything is
uh
potentially problematic but could
something really
uh surprising come up it can come up and
that's why you need to address
what you will do if you have problems
like that right now nevada has no
oversight of any midwives through senate
bill 271
senator hammond is proposing the
creation of a board of certified
professional midwives
licensing for cpms and permits for
apprentices
with oversight there would be
regulations and disciplinary action
would be possible
while assembly bill 387 is similar
it states if an unlicensed person
practices midwifery
they must obtain a statement from a
client acknowledging
they know the person is not regulated by
the state
if the midwife doesn't get that
statement they could be charged with a
misdemeanor crime
it also lists guidelines for when a cpm
must arrange for consultation with a
health care provider
what midwifery care is here in nevada
now
is unregulated and that's why it's
unsafe i hope it allows
consumers to have freedom of choice as
well as to have
midwives have a good path to getting
licensed
that is not too onerous for them to meet
the legislation is currently being
considered
no hearings have been scheduled yet
vanessa murphy
8 news now the i-team checked in with
local hospitals to find out whether they
have relationships with midwives
you can find that information at eight
newsnow dot com as well as the i-team's
report on midwifery which aired at six
o'clock